Yeah,
the travel to Spain.
Have you ever visited Barcelona in the
or?
Maybe the Canary Islands?
Well,
if you have ensure there is something
isn't much.
Have surprised you decide the facts.
That scene isn't a crisis.
And as the second highest unemployment
rates in all of Europe and a wealthy
country facilities,
uh,
clean the roads of brand new pavements,
there are international airports and
every other city and this state of the
art high speed train network throughout
most of the time.
Sure.
At least on the surface.
Madrid has no reasons to be jealous of
Zurich London.
Then again,
we also came out as a country that was
at the edge of bankruptcy,
not such a long time and go and now has
gone through one of the biggest
political crisis in their recent
history.
Premier will have to leave the
government.
Congress has passed and impeachment bill
impeachment means that the congress,
that is the legislative power loops to
kick the executive out.
Unlike other countries like America in
Spain,
you need to propose an alternative
governments that will substitute for the
format.
This makes impeachments attempts almost
impossible to pull off in this country,
but these all strange days and Spanish
political life's the brand new Spanish
presidents and the Social Democrats,
Padre Sanchez has managed to convince
the radical left the nationalist right,
and so the independent Catalunian
parties to vote against the conservative
government of Marianna at a height they
will have one thing in common.
They didn't want more of this,
and now you might be wondering,
why did Roy have so many haters?
Well,
while you might think it's corruption,
and of course this is the official
reason,
but beyond the surface,
that's way more of that.
As we said before,
Spain is one of the most damaged
countries from the big financial crisis
of 2008,
and the forming government likes to brag
about that economic achievements with
statements like this one
been an honor to leave this country in
better shape than I found it.
Marianna over to Hawaii.
This is why in today's video we have a
lot of questions to cover.
First has gotten over the crisis
already.
Science and economic growth and
unemployment reduction.
This country still has more than 16
percent unemployment rates and other
countries like Ireland driving faster
than stain,
so can we really save that they've left
the financial crisis behinds and if so,
what credit because we give to the
conservative
governments also.
Is it a good moment to invest in Spain
today?
We're going to answer with these
questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at the history
black.
In the year 2002,
the eurozone was created.
All of the sudden Spain,
Germany,
France,
and many other countries started to use
the same currency,
the euro,
and the same interest rates.
The ones that the European central bank
fixes.
This seems to be a great idea.
Having the same currency,
a German bank and lends money to a
Spanish company on the same conditions
as they wish a German company,
but these advantages come with a risk.
If Spain goes bankrupt,
this German bank with Spanish debt might
get bankrupts too.
In other words,
if a country does poorly,
they might spread to the problems to
other countries.
Swipe.
When you join the euro,
you must follow some rules.
One of them is that no country can have
a deficit.
They got them three percent.
This means they cannot spend more than
what they collect in taxes.
They said,
let's fast forward to listening in
history to the year 2008,
the year of the international financial
crisis.
Many European countries suffer this pain
among them.
Suddenly the unemployment rate goes sky
high until it's the pasta 20 percent.
This means that all of a sudden the
government collects little money in
taxes during that,
those international apolis and high
speed trains.
I told you about,
well,
assassinating not cheap,
and this is why the inevitable happened.
Spain,
Greece,
and Ireland had the highest budget
deficits in the EU in 2012.
Maximum deficits at urec country could
have was three percent saying 10
percent.
This meant nobody wanted to lend money
to their governments.
At the end of the day,
are you going to pay it back when you
spend 10 percent more than what you
collect?
If you've followed visual politics for a
long time,
you already know what happens when
investors don't trust your credit
reliability,
rice,
and see
what did they do well?
Yep,
exactly.
They asked for higher interest rates.
Now listen,
up in the euro zone,
we have an index to measure the chances
of a country to forcing.
It's the so called risk.
Yeah.
Basically what they do is take the most
trustworthy debts,
phones that exists in Europe.
This is the German bonds.
Then they can pay the interest rate of
the German bonds with the interest rates
of the other ones.
The number that against with this
comparison is called the risk premium,
so in the year 2010,
the Spanish debt at a risk premium of 50
points,
and this was okay,
but one year later it had 250,
which is five times more
Spanish bonds at brisk as contained
gathers force,
and this is where the men in black came
into the eviction.
Yes.
The men in black wasn't an given by the
journalist to the European Central Bank
workers.
These ECV people.
When's the most problematic countries in
the euro zone and requested that they
follow the rules.
Basically what they said was,
it says right here that you concept the
deficit bigger than three percent,
but your giving crazy stop wasting money
or will punish you.
In countries like Ireland,
these men in black where especially
strict and some even forced the
parliaments of choose another prime
minister who was more fiscally
responsible,
but one of them is insane.
What did these men in black do
in the country of Sangria and Pieta?
November the 20th,
2011.
This is the day when these Spanish
people's party kicks us in the
elections.
The Conservative leader,
Mariana or Ohio becomes one of the most
supportive leaders in Europe and he
supposed to buy it.
Viktor Orban in Hungary,
the Spanish people's Party.
Your as it's fascinating,
pep got 53 percent of the seats in
Congress ends.
They ruled in most of the regional
government.
Basically Mr Roy was so popular that he
could have probably gotten away with
changing the name of Spain to recoil
lands.
So what was this political program
during the elections?
Well,
basically Roy sent to the European
Central Bank
guys,
don't worry unconservative,
so I know my economics first going to
reduce taxes and then I'm going to make
loads of business friendly reforms that
would make this country like silicon
valley than those companies helped
people make billions hoppy
and same deficit problem solves.
All right guys.
Basically the whole campaign was based
on the idea of like taxes.
The mantra for any problem was to reduce
taxes and everything
by most important.
Did you know the.
What they say during the electoral
campaign is one thing and what they do
one day after taking office is another
thing entirely.
Government must raise some taxes for
some time in Florida.
During the months of Roy,
the government raised the taxes
including VAT,
income tax and all the special taxes on
tobacco in gasoline.
Yup.
A Conservative government made the
biggest tax increase in Spanish history.
I want about all of these wonderful
business regulations that would turn
Spain into the new silicon valley.
Well,
you can imagine what happens with that
one.
So what happens when you promise a
business friendly agenda and it's come
up with the opposite ones here in
office?
Well,
devices,
they get angry,
but there's nothing they can really do
until the next election.
But the international investors,
they can give you their backs the very
moment you break that trust,
and this is exactly what happened in
Spain.
Spanish academy in huge crisis after
credit downgrade.
Basically the Spanish debt bombs fell
into the category of trash.
You remember about that risk premium
that I told you about earlier.
So at some points it went to the Satanic
Sega of six,
six,
many Spanish banks were to the edge of
bankruptcy and no one wanted to buy any
Spanish debt.
Spain,
it was about to collapse and that would
mean no money to pay doctors,
school teachers,
and tax collectors.
Only one team though anyone could solve
this problem.
Black
to accept rescue from Europe for an
ailing banks.
So what was this all about?
Basically,
Europe would lend money at a lower
interest rate,
so Spanish banks could not go bankrupt.
In exchange,
they requested the government to cut
spending.
And here is where did his big bad ass
movement,
or as we like to call it,
roughly and nomics basically,
once the European Central Bank had
already nailed down,
the banks were highly to those men in
black and set essentially.
What's up dudes,
you think you could tell me what to do.
Look at these bad boys.
Siri was the stainless too big to fail.
So despite having the worst credit
rating,
you can imagine the European Central
Bank would eventually buy all the debt
bonds without asking to any interest
rates.
How well printing money with this money
Stan could keep being as it was,
without making any costly reforms that
well.
Now the question is,
why would the ECB acceptable of this?
That's actually easy because stain has
the fourth biggest economy in Europe and
nobody's going to let it fail.
Sorry.
The months while they kept passing,
unemployment's kept growing and so did
that risk premium.
The conservative governments of the
People's party far from making business
friendly reforms.
They did about an example prior to them.
The professional services like taxi
drivers were going to the liberalized
insane taxi driver.
Associations are well connected with the
conservative,
so the right wing pasta bill to protect
taxi drivers from competition.
This is why many sharing economy
companies like either an Addie and dee
now have many,
many restrictions in the Spanish market.
The question is
the real challenge the European Central
Bank works and the answer is,
Oh yeah,
these say B is ready to do whatever it
takes to preserve the euro and believe
me,
it wouldn't be enough for Mario comes to
the rescue
four months,
the ECB president's,
Mario Draghi said he would not
compromise with stain.
Basically rewired wanted him to print
more money so he could buy a Spanish
desks and otherwise Roy wanted the
wealthier countries like Germany and
sendlane's do give money to stain at no
political cost just because,
well apparently reasons it doesn't sound
very fair,
does it?
Well,
sometimes three rounds he has.
Life's not fair and Roy,
he was right.
Spain,
Mr.
thanks
b could be ready to buy week Italian
Spanish bonds.
Since then,
25 percent of the Spanish debt is in ECB
hands and those words from Mario Draghi
saying he would do whatever it takes to
save the euro like magic.
One day at a time the risk premium of
Spain started falling.
Investors don't in buying debt phones
because they knew they had the backing
of the ECB,
and this is stain could keep piling on
more and more debt.
This country now has a depth that
represents more than a hundred percent
of that entire GDP.
Meanwhile,
the rest of the European countries have
started growing.
Two Thousand and 12 Gemini has become
the biggest export powerhouse in the
entire wells.
China has gone from being the world
sanctuary to developing brands,
new consumer market where everybody can
sell their products.
In other words,
every European country is growing now
and that of course does include Spain.
Nonetheless,
this was good news is every government's
like good news.
Spain has got over the crisis in record
time.
This is already 2015 in this.
Yes.
Staying at elections again and the
government decides to celebrate at the
end of the crisis with a tax cut in the
middle of the electoral campaign.
Pretty Brilliant News,
right?
You raise taxes at the beginning of one
election and then one year before the
next election you put them where they
used to be.
I think that's what happened right after
he won the elections again.
Yeah.
Guess
right?
Is his taxes again in 2017,
the government will have to cut $15
million in its deficit.
Is it going?
Imagine raising and reducing taxes
depending on when you have elections is
not the best policy.
If you want to attract foreign investors
and red tape,
that's almost the same if not more
prevalent than before,
and if you consider all the territorial
problems,
you'll understand why the unemployment
rate in stain is still a 16 percent.
Other countries
he's in the eurozone like Estonia and
islands,
which had really bad recessions are now
way better than 10 years ago.
While Spain remains though.
Now it's your son.
Do you think that the brand new Spanish
government can do any worse than the
previous one?
Do you think Spain has sold its crisis?
Do you think there's lots of work still
to do that?
Well,
please leave your answer in the comment
section below and also visit our friends
from the reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
the one on mine,
and as always,
don't forget to support us on patrion
where you'll gain exclusive access to a
lot of contents and many wonderful
gifts.
If you like this video,
give it a thumbs up.
As always,
I'll see you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice,
you can join
us@reconsidermediacastatreconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast.
You Bet.